Speaker 1: I talked about this next story
on last Friday's bonus show, but it's just
such an important media story. I thought it'd
be good to cover again today for the general
David Pakman show audience, and that is that as I
was watching day one of the January 6th hearings
last Thursday, I couldn't help but wonder,
is Fox News broadcasting this? Because
on the one hand, it's a highly relevant thing
that's going on in the world of politics. So
you'd think that a news and politics TV station
would have to cover it. On the other hand,
the January six hearings are really making Trump
look bad, really making his allies look bad,
and even making Fox News personalities look
bad. Because, you know, we found out about
how Sean HANNITY was texting Kayleigh MCENANY
as the Capitol riots were unfolding, trying to
get her to get the president to get his supporters
out of the Capitol on that day. Well, what I saw
was Tucker Carlson show, and they had a live feed
up of the hearing, but they weren't playing audio
from it. They were just showing the visuals. And
Tucker went on the show and he brought on guests
and he was complaining about how the whole ordeal
was overblown and how we're not talking about the
real issues because we're so wrapped up at January
6th. Still, Carlson called the hearing deranged.
He called it insulting, and he took a moral stand.
He said that he was going to simply refuse to play
along the lower third graphics during the show.
That's the sirens at the bottom. They were saying
things like January 6th committee fuels false
narratives as sham investigation draws on. There
was another one that said leaders will spend 90
minutes giving moral lecture. A third one said,
Our leaders are focusing on January 6th
while ignoring the real threats. Here's a
clip from Tucker Carlson's opening monologue.
Speaker 2: Good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson. You know, it tells you a lot about the
priorities of our ruling class that the rest of
us are getting yet. Another lecture about January
six tonight from our moral inferiors, no less,
an outbreak of mob violence, a forgettable
minor outbreak by recent standards that
took place more than a year and a half ago,
but they've never stopped talking about it.
In the meantime, in the 18 months since January
six, gas prices have doubled. Drug loads have
reached their highest point ever. The U.S. economy
is now careening toward a devastating recession
at best. And scariest and least noted of all,
this country has never in its history been
closer to a nuclear war. Yet the other networks
cannot be bothered to cover any of that tonight.
Instead, they've interrupted the regularly
scheduled programing to bring you yet another
extended primetime harangue from Nancy Pelosi
and Liz Cheney about Donald Trump and Q and on.
The whole thing is insulting. In fact,
it's deranged and we're not playing along.
This is the only hour on an American news channel
that will not be carrying their propaganda live.
They are lying and we are not going to help
them do it. What we will do instead is to try
to tell you the truth. We've attempted
to do that since the day this happened.
We hated seeing vandalism at the US Capitol a
year and a half ago and we said so at the time,
but we did not think it was an insurrection
because it was not an insurrection. It
was not even close to an insurrection.
Speaker 1: Now, it's also interesting in
all of this is that during the entire broadcast,
they didn't actually cut to a commercial break.
And you have to wonder why that is, right? Because
it's a TV show. Like any other show. You're going
to go to commercials every 15 minutes to
give time for the sponsors. Well, what
appears to have happened is that Fox executives
didn't want people to have the opportunity to
change the channel. Right. Because if they go to
break at Fox, maybe people will tune over to CNN
or another news station, and then maybe they'll
come across the hearings with the audio and then
they may actually learn a thing or two about
January 6th. So couldn't have that, which meant
that you couldn't have commercials. And that's
really telling, right? Because on the one hand,
Fox is saying that January 6th there was nothing.
BERGER There's too much focus on it. It was just
a tourist visit, nothing to see here. And on the
other hand, they're unwilling to go to commercial
breaks. They're unwilling to broadcast the hearing
with audio. So they definitely have something to
hide when it comes to all of this. And they want
to make sure that their viewers don't learn too
much more about the events of January 6th and the
lead up. Now, I'm sure we'll be talking more about
the hearings as they continue this week. But to
be honest, from day one of the hearings, I had
mixed feelings because I thought that the video
testimonies, those were effective. I thought that
the footage of the riots and, you know, the Trump
supporters who are fighting with the cops and all
that stuff, I thought it was very effective. What
I didn't think was so effective was some of the
long winded speeches and the testimony from the
police officer and the documentarian and the focus
on the proud boys and all that stuff. I think
if it was a little bit more condensed, it would
be more effective, but that's just my view anyway.
You're trying to appeal to people who haven't made
up their minds when it comes to January 6th, and
I think less is more when it comes to this stuff.
So we'll we'll see what happens over the next few
days as the hearings continue. If they are able
to engage with the audience any better and if the
public is able to come away from this all thinking
that there really needs to be consequences for
the people who were involved on January 6th,
because it was a terrible thing that happens in
our country and it should never happen again.